Chelsea Lynn she has a character named
trailer trash Tammy she has the viral
podcast more big fans over here let's
give her a warm welcome from trash
Tuesday
much for coming in thank you all for
having me and I'm ready to get trashy my
favorite videos of of you are with Paige
and that
um when she's like laid on her stomach
and she farts out the powder what
you don't follow her I do but I haven't
seen that oh yeah nothing will bring you
more joy in this lifetime I watched that
thing before I sleep ever oh my God that
was um that's one of my favorite videos
we've ever done and we've done a couple
where she's farted out powder right and
I think she's just just a professional
like Gas machine oh dude she knows what
foods to eat before if we know we're
gonna do a Fart Powder video she she has
a lineup of what to eat and surprisingly
Tomatoes is on there oh Tomatoes is
horrible for your gut that's why I could
fart out some powder I could find out
some blood if I eat tomatoes oh God oh
God yeah so thank you you this one that
that one was we filmed that at the
height of the pandemic you know when
like if they had different levels of
like um like businesses were closing if
it was level I don't care I can't even
remember what it was if it was level
green everything was close so we wanted
to do like a
um a spoof of that like a new spoof we
couldn't get through it we were laughing
so hard
and she wanted to redo it I said
absolutely not we're posting that
and it just went it went kind of viral
so yeah yeah can you pull it up um
Carlos so Esther can see it seems to be
multi there's many it's
um I think it's pinned to my Instagram
but maybe the quickest way to find it
um but yeah you gotta watch
you gotta watch it and people always ask
us about the powder we get it from Party
City oh shout out Party City and I don't
know what it's for it's just colored
baby powder and I will literally here we
go that's it that's it oh my God oh my
it's already better than I could have
imagined and she's so hot too
wait
okay this is this is art
like I genuinely feel like this is what
art should be you're like creatively
expressing yourselves
and it's bringing Joy what else does art
what what else could art do elicits a
really big emotion out of me and I think
it's like you know you have the Maria
bramovich and they do these really big
performance art installations but that
to me is the winner and she sells fart
art where she will she will Fart Powder
on a canvas
and she sells it
this is like okay I feel like this is a
technique that you guys should be
licensing out to hot girls on Tick Tock
so that they can then like you should
sell the powder to them and then they
figured it out and they sell it to horny
men yes well there she is doing a fart
art right there
and this is this is Paige gin uh she's
my best friend we she does the podcast
with me devour podcast and there it is
yes and she will gloss it up with you
know she'll make it all nice and stuff
and and she will sell those
[ __ ] Carlos I've never seen you
fist pump the air he's excited I did but
it's just too funny it's so cute yeah
it's the way it could it's great dude
like I'll be honest when you guys start
talking about farting out powders I'm
like okay I'm a little skeptical and
then you see it and you're like oh this
is like human expression and it's kind
of like most unique form farting out
powders oh my God and we're grown ass
women in our 30s that's the best that's
the best oh my God that's that's that's
all the comments we get about this show
they're like these girls are pushing 40
and we love the [ __ ] are they doing it's
like we figured it out we're just not
insecure in our 20s so we're doing
whatever we want yes it's like this is
the best time of our lives and if you're
a listener and you're in your 20s get
started now yeah don't wait don't wait
for some type of like
um green light to get started on the
fart art I love that
just start farting yeah be free
this show is sponsored by Better Health
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp
help.com trash Tuesday thank you to our
sponsor next Evo the holidays are not
all sleigh bells and mistletoe there are
also airports shopping malls and dining
tables crowded with people some you're
glad to only see once a year get smarter
CBD from next Evo Naturals and get up to
25 off subscription orders of forty
dollars or more at nextevo.com podcast
promo code trash Tuesday that's n e x t
e v o.com slash podcast promo code trash
Tuesday this holiday season if you're
looking for a unique gift that inspires
curiosity travel and culture a give the
gift a babble Babble is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions right now get up
to 55 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com trash Tuesday that's
babble.com trash Tuesday for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for Life ZocDoc is a free app that shows
you doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance and are available
when you need them go to zocdoc.com
trash and download the ZocDoc app for
free then start your search for a top
rated doctor today many are available
within 24 hours that
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash hi
guys I am going to be doing stand-up in
Phoenix January 6th and 7th you can get
tickets at Esther onice.com and also
check out my solo show so my pleasure
it's available wherever you listen to
your podcasts
sluggies insanies stannies or fans
whatever you're called
um my new solo podcast is up anniewood
you can check it out every Tuesday after
trash Tuesdays it comes out on noon on
my YouTube channel Annie Letterman go
we've been live chatting it's been so
fun also I am on the road I'm having the
best time seeing all of you guys you can
see me next this New Year's I'm gonna be
in Vegas December 30th and 31st at Wise
Guys it's just absolute Heaven I cannot
wait to party with you guys I'm going to
be at Flappers in Burbank January 7th or
one night you can see me in Wisconsin
Florida and Canada and a lot more dates
are coming so go to annieleterman.com
shows to check those out I cannot wait
to meet you
I was um I my sister who's in town from
the Philippines told me something really
crazy yesterday or last night
um so my teeth I have gaps in my teeth
and they're starting to kind of push out
a little bit so that I'm gonna be
Michael Strahan in about three months oh
my God lucky and so now I'm like oh my
God like should I call an orthodontist
because there's a certain level of Gap
that I'm comfortable with and she goes
oh she's like don't even do that let it
Gap out completely because she was like
my sister-in-law did this her her teeth
shifted so far apart that instead of
buying braces all she could afford was
an extra tooth so she put a single tooth
right in the middle of where the Gap was
stop
that [ __ ] genius God so this woman
just rolls around which is a giant tooth
in the middle just one tooth that feels
more alien presenting than like having a
gap that's so scary
so funny oh that's great
that's amazing oh God so should I
[Laughter]
please I'm serious that's [ __ ]
awesome I feel like that is also
performance art it is I would love to
see you go more in the direction of like
let that Gap spread open and just like
have it be an expression of like
horniness like I'm open I'm ready like
it's you know like I will make guys
think that like you know they can fit
their wiener in between yeah we did
Madonna fix her Gap I think Madonna the
story with her is that she fixed it and
regrets fixing it or is that lady got
the signature yeah look right yeah she's
slaying on Tick Tock she really is what
are your thoughts on body modifications
she looks great
no she I dude people are like the
comments are just dragging like what the
hell I think it's hilarious I think it
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah who cares at
that point she doesn't give a [ __ ] this
is sort of like the existential crisis
that I've been having this week which is
like I feel like at 8am I drink an
almond milk latte and I'm like I am
smart and I have things to say and then
like at 10 o'clock at night I take a
weed gummy and I'm like oh my God I'm
the most in everything I think and say
is embarrassing I hate myself it's like
why am I trying I should just like hide
forever and I feel like I the ideal is
to just land at a place like Madonna
where you're just doing whatever you
want you don't judge it you don't care
let everyone [ __ ] have their ideas
about you like how is that not the best
option well then let me have my one
front tooth after fine
yes I agree with you though honestly
that's the way to do it like what it
like I actually feel like I need advice
from you guys like if I I'm in a mode
where I feel insecure and I'm like
reading like everyone I don't know I'm
like reading a Reddit that's making fun
of people and like I start to feel
embarrassed about my thoughts and the
things I share like what would your
advice be to me I'm a I'm a big like
glass half full person and for me if I
if I see a negative comment or someone
like that's not funny you're stupid
whatever man I I think about I put that
in the back of my head and I think about
the hundreds of comments from people
that are like oh my God that was
hilarious that made my [ __ ] day like
you have to think about that instead of
you know I guess just rewire how rewire
what your brain thinks is important I
guess yeah because yeah a negative
comment is not it literally means
nothing to me when I have a thousand
great comments right you just have to
think about that yeah you know that's a
little cheesy but it's true no I like
that yeah because you do seem like a
very positive uplifting person like
you're just about spreading joy and like
nothing else really what else matters
right exactly and Chelsea you didn't
have it easy growing up either oh hell
no oh hell I had a really rough
upbringing yeah
um parents were meth heads
um I grew up in a in a trailer house we
I mean I grew up in poverty you know a
lot of people say like oh we were poor
growing up I'm like no no you weren't
you had a trampoline [ __ ] you
were doing good okay
um I grew up I mean our trailer house
had just big holes in the floor that we
would have to like hop over wait didn't
weren't there snakes that lived well in
the summer we would have we would put
plywood over it so because there's
snakes everywhere in Oklahoma so they
wouldn't you know come up and
um oh gosh I remember
um honestly when I was really young I
got taken away when I was 12 to go live
with my grandma but before that
um when I was with my parents they would
be gone for days at a time when I was
like six seven eight years old and no
food in the house I would literally have
to go around the neighborhood and not
walk on the door and be like
can like and I had two little sisters
I'm the oldest of three and be like do
you guys have any food like that was my
so it's hard for me I can I always think
[ __ ] could be worse
life could be worse
you know like that's it's hard for me to
like focus on the negatives when I'm
like bro like it it could just be worse
that is such an incredible perspective
that you've been given because of that
like
you're so right like how could anything
be that bad if that's like what you had
to deal with as a sixth year especially
if your basic needs are not met right
that's like of all the things like food
clothing shelter like if you don't even
have that like what else could you even
be like upset about you know that's what
I'm saying and like my my parents
weren't like abusive to us but we were
abused in in a neglect way in that way
well because neglect is yes yeah yeah
and and so I think that's why I'm so
like just you know I'm not really like a
body positive influence or anything but
I just live it and people are always
like how are you so like you know I and
not even just big girls I will have thin
girls come up to me like how how are you
so confident how do I get that and I'm
like bro how could I as a 13 year old
girl
be worried about cellulite when I was
worried about surviving
you think I was worried about oh my God
I have a role that was the least [ __ ]
thing that was so far back in my mind
that did not even matter so that's kind
of a blessing in disguise to me because
the whole like you know how teenage
girls just struggle with their body I
never went through that I was trying to
live you know I never went through any
of that so I've always just been you
know like I don't know it's just hard
for me to it's hard for me to to be
negative about myself when it's just
[ __ ] like that's not important right wow
you know yeah no I just got serious on
on this pod I love it yeah because I
think um a lot of times like
there are people that I see in my life
that just feel like
um like I want to model after I have a
friend named Marianne who's very similar
to you just had like when I knew her
growing up she lived under the bleachers
of the
um I I trained every day in this one
because I was a swimmer and they had
bleachers on the side and she lived
underneath the bleachers I'm still
friends with her to this day and when I
look at her she just has a big Joy about
her and this like just zest for life and
that's very similar to you and I'm I
always like it is such it is such a
grounding feeling to be around her
because I'm like dude [ __ ] doesn't
matter like this [ __ ] is happy like she
is just raring to go and I really like I
like I look up to that yeah I look up to
that I look up to that when I'm having
my little first world meltdowns over
some [ __ ] that doesn't matter and not to
say that I'm like like invalidating like
my own feelings because any problem
small or big is a problem if you feel
feel it right but still it does give you
perspective and it kind of shakes you
out of whatever [ __ ] tantrum you want
to throw that day about some petty [ __ ]
exactly damn I just wonder like how how
is it that so many people more so I
think tend to default to like they put
the bad things that that they had to go
through in this category of like why
this happened to me and now I'm screwed
and like like Carlos and I were talking
about this a little bit yesterday like
you go into a loop of like blame and
that will just like completely derail
your life and you almost like lose
control over it because you're just so
focused on blaming these bad
circumstances like I'm so guilty I think
like everyone does it to varying degrees
and I'm like how do you how do you like
become this version instead like that's
so remarkable to me I've thought about
that yeah a lot yeah because my life
could have gone a big time different
direction was there ever a point where
you were like like oh [ __ ] like I'm not
doing well I'm coping poorly and I'm
turning to things that are like
unhealthy or were you always just like
no I I I distinctively remember I was
about 10 years old we were living in
Sulfur Oklahoma
and right beside this Oklahoma school of
the deaf I don't know why I remember
that but I was on the front porch and I
literally remember this and I think
about it all the time
I remember I don't think my mom had been
home in like a week don't know where she
was
um and I remember just looking around
and going
this ain't gonna be my life
hmm
nope
I'm gonna live a good life I'm gonna
live a happy life I this whatever has
been going on you know the last 10 years
my whole life not gonna be me
I remember thinking that at 10 years old
and that just stuck with me so hard in
in pretty much every like major decision
I've ever made you know I truly thought
that as a little kid not this ain't
gonna be me nope it's so interesting
it's like you made a decision that in
there and then like because of that
decision all of your actions like we're
in alignment from then on with that
decision like that's almost like exactly
what manifesting is I know that word is
no haha whatever but yeah it's like you
decided and then you take action exactly
exactly that's cool maybe I'm just in
like a need for uplifting today and
that's why I'm directing the
conversation this way but like it I just
feel very inspired by you you have like
such a warm like happy energy oh honey
thank you you're gonna make me tear up
here thank you I appreciate that please
adopt me
what does your shirt say oh God I had to
wear it for you guys I just I'm seeing
just the word boner and it's making me
so happy right now and was like this is
the shirt I'm wearing on the pod
I I have explosive diarrhea and a boner
that is the show
that is all the show is I I was looking
through my closet I was packing I was
like what am I going to wear on the pot
and I was like yep we're just honestly
we're just come dumb [ __ ] same I know
you are same that's why I'm so happy
you're here yes you don't hold back you
like to talk about [ __ ] coming real
hard all of the things I love it two of
my favorite topics
I love it and dude people are so oh my
gosh like I've been doing this I've been
doing the whole social media thing for
almost probably nine years now and it
has not gotten easier with people being
like Oh that's inappropriate that's
that's you shouldn't say [ __ ] you man
like I oh my God and my stand-up is just
is even better
I love it I just think you
um [ __ ] real good when I look at you I'm
like that's a [ __ ] who [ __ ] good oh my
God that was the Nazis you ever said to
me I'm saying it with my whole chest too
oh my God I am horny me too I'm not even
kidding I'm I'm horny 24 7 that my
husband hates me
[Laughter]
it's bad I'm not even kidding what do
you ask for if he's just like I cannot
[ __ ] you right now that's that's him 24
7. I can't and it's been we've been
together for God
16 17 years yeah and it really hasn't
you know oh I'd love a fresh piece you
know
but but I just stay I just stay horny
and I don't know what it is and I just
talk about it I masturbate a lot I talk
about that dude I have had this is
mind-blowing because when I post [ __ ] I
don't expect it to do anything for
people I'm just posting [ __ ] cause I'm
[ __ ] dumb you know what I mean you're
expressing yourself yeah I'm just
whatever and I post about masturbating a
lot or whatever which you know is
probably a lot to a lot of people but I
have had It's never enough not for me I
mean I literally will get messages
people at shows come up to me like I oh
my god I've had women come to me crying
being like Chelsea I have been like
ashamed that I master I keep it a secret
I tell people I don't I've been so
that's such a big thing for women it
really is I remember being really sh
like feeling such dread and shame the
first time I stuck a toothbrush up my
[ __ ] when I was in high school because
that's all that was available it was
like the bristle end perfume bottles
I'm not kidding I'm not kidding go ahead
mine just seems so not fun but I
remember because like I grew up in a
very like Catholic nation and even
though my family was very the women in
my family were vocal about sex you just
don't really talk about masturbating and
it's like there I was like just 15 and
horny and the toothbrush looked like a
great solution at that time but I
remember coming and then feeling like
what have I done and then I wrote in my
journal like dear God like please
forgive me because I thought it was a
sin
that [ __ ] was clean it was cleaned out
you clean that thing out
well it's like I feel like this all goes
back to my new platform which is being
anti-capitalism which like that we never
are taught or encouraged to have like
female pleasure because all that matters
is like a man Go-Go's inside of us and
then we raise children that will work it
like in the in our country and so like
there's just no acknowledgment it that
we even should or get to have joy and
fun from sex right but the way I talk to
my nieces now who are 14 and 21 every
day it's a reminder it's like you're
you come good you come hard and you make
you you his job is to make you come like
don't forget that tattoo that [ __ ] on
your arm I come first I come first dude
I asked my nieces
a couple weeks ago I was like you guys
humping your pillows yet
one of them got all weird and I go bro
look at her face you're humping your
pillows
she got so embarrassed I go she's the
one that started I love that but like I
you know wanted perfect let's go back to
perfume okay okay because I want to know
what what which perfume bottles it was I
don't know if y'all have heard of this
brand but it's real big in the South
Brighton I gotta see this can you pick
that up it's really big and you may even
find the perfume bottle it's really uh a
lot of older southern women wear
brighten jewelry and they have per
that's the bottle right there right
there that's it and it had Live Laugh
Love on it
that's the bottle stuck that in me
that was the that was the very first
thing wait which end which end the round
end yep yep
and I didn't get more than the lid in
there because I was scared you know but
I stuck it in there is this do you think
there's any connection to why you like
to wear a lot of perfume to this day is
it like a very like intimate I never
thought about that but you're probably
right like that's like your first sort
of experience you had you're probably
right but that was it it had Live Laugh
Love on it I'll never forget that
but um yeah my I talk about it a lot and
my you know if I'll do like a q a on
Instagram and somebody says how do you
you know relax I'm like I'll rub one out
and just you know like I just because
it's the truth and one of my best
friends since childhood she was raised
in a very religious
um household
and God she told me not too long ago she
had told me her whole life that she'd
never masturbated never never once and I
kept saying you are that is the craziest
thing I've ever heard in my life and she
came in not too long ago and she was
like Chelsea I just gotta tell you like
I've been masturbating this whole time
and I'm like you lied to me she goes I
had so much shame what from the way she
was raised and she goes and I know that
I know you and you're you were like best
friends but she goes just like watching
your Instagram has like changed my life
and my mind about
about that and I get that all the time
and here I am thinking I'm just talking
about rubbing one out you know but it's
true it like it that just goes to show
like the [ __ ] we post that we think is
like not a big deal is a big deal to a
lot of people which is wild this is like
the thing that I feel like I'm
continually learning it's like the more
I share even though I feel some shame
and like embarrassment about it
sometimes when I'm really high like but
the more I share the more I feel like
I'm really deeply connecting with others
on like a human level and the more I'm
reminded that we're all the same and
having like a human experience and I'm
like at least there's that yeah like at
least there's that at least it's not
just me like you know and you would I
would much rather present myself as a
walking disaster of a human than
anything else yes because like truly
like my my biggest fear is that I ever
present as a put together adult because
I certainly don't feel that way they
today and if anyone ever comes up to me
and says hey you just like you look like
you know how to do it I'd be so
disappointed by myself I'm like because
I don't I don't know how to do [ __ ] I
just know that coming feels good and I
talk about that a lot
yeah that's it no I love that you're not
fake or trying to pretend that you know
your life's perfect and that's you know
a lot of people on social media are like
that yeah not us
I wouldn't be
jack [ __ ] if I didn't have therapy in my
life same same same like therapy has
we've talked about this a lot it's like
it's made me a person that focuses on
Solutions and not problems it's made me
a person that can
um sit with my feelings and not just
like act on them like therapy has done
so much for me that nothing else could
have ever done for me it's the most
self-loving thing that I um do in my
life like even if I'm not necessarily
having like a challenging week even just
a check in with someone who I know has
good Insight or tools to help even like
small things that you don't necessarily
think I'm like wait I think I can handle
this you know just checking in with a
professional it really just sort of like
cleans the windshield a little bit Yeah
it helps you get out of like the
feelings of things and just be able to
look at what is happening observe it
with someone that can help you pick out
patterns and stuff that yeah and these
therapists are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
really could not be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist learn more and
save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday that's
betterhelph-help.com trash Tuesday
work
I got trouble sleeping I get hyper after
my sets I'm so hyper when I get home
from The Comedy Store or when I'm on the
road I am
my body is exhausted my brain is wide
awake and I am not I am not interested
in any THC anymore
I am all CBD next Evo is changing the
game for me I totally relate to that and
I totally agree like that feeling of not
being able to sleep I really need
something to relax me and also for the
holidays I love my family I'm so excited
to see them but that doesn't mean it
doesn't come with like
anxiety tension stress like all these
things creep up and I need to be armored
with protection and that's when bringing
a next Evo CBD with me and nextiva is
awesome because it's fast absorbing it
it's it's fast acting it absorbs it's
just like
well what you're I know what you're
talking about next Evo smart sorb
technology delivers CBD to your system
in as little as 10 minutes unlike other
CBD Brands and regular CBD oil it works
more slowly because of how our bodies
process oil-based ingredients compared
to water soluble supplements so there's
like science and facts as to why we like
this right and they're complex gummies
they're clinically proven to have four
times that's four times better
absorption than standard CBD no other
CBD brand can promise that get smarter
CBD from next Evo Naturals and get up to
25 off subscription orders of forty
dollars or more at next evo.com podcast
promo code trash Tuesday
yeah
that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast promo
code trash Tuesday so I also want to
point out that the comp the CBD complex
gummies that they have feature
ashwagandha which is clinically proven
to reduce stress by 70 so ashwagandha
and CBD together is like that's where
it's at yeah stress is over guys we're
done with it right yeah we don't want to
do that anymore it's leaking your power
you need tools to help you just chill
and relax this is the stuff
Chelsea I want to say that I know that
you had it rough upbringing because both
of your parents were meth heads and
there was neglect but I want to ask you
about this form of abuse that I um
suffered when I was younger
um I I was a swimmer so we would swim
twice a day every day since I was like
eight years old but my mom I just had
this memory that my mom would make us
swim through lightning storms so like we
we didn't have like it was an outdoor
pool and it would be like a full-blown
electrical storm and then she would look
at the sky and then we would be like ma
should we get out the water and she's
like no you're good and for two hours we
would just like hear like the Thunder
and we were just praying that it
wouldn't strike the water okay there is
something kind of cool about that
like your mom is so badass
that is crazy she's like if my kid turns
to powder you know that movie like [ __ ]
it he'll come out as farts later oh my
gosh but then isn't that like an insane
way to parent to put fear in you like
that like I could die at any minute well
she was playing God she was just like I
think no we're good like she was sure it
wasn't gonna hit the water
oh my gosh look I have to say this do
you want to grow up as an and become an
Esther like your mom did something right
like I am so scared of my own shadow and
I feel like if I had had that experience
I would be braver and like better for it
but I I I might be speaking so out of
turn and totally wrong because it
clearly it's terrifying yeah I don't
know sorry I was trying to do man I
don't know was she hoping for some
lightning I don't know
what was she rooting for there was a
part of me she always wanted boys and
there's a part of me that truly thinks
like sometimes I thought as a child I
was like I think she wants is dead damn
I think that you know she's just praying
for just one bolt to hit me right at the
top of my head as soon as you said that
story that's what I was thinking
Dan do you have a good relationship with
her now I do yeah she's she's a
completely different person you should
straight up ask her were you trying to
kill us
no she um she probably would say yes
that's why well okay so having that
experience like how do you think like
swimming in like a fair being very
scared you're about to be struck by
lightning like how does what has that
done to you
um I I you want to touch my armpits like
even talking about it like I'm sweating
it's just it's it's one of those things
that like you know like you can
intellectualize all of the bad things
that happen to you and you can even put
a positive spin to it but it doesn't
mean it's not going to find its way into
the way your body acts like you your
brain can be fully accepting of all the
situations but sometimes your body just
reacts in ways you don't understand and
I think that's where the lightning storm
comes in where it's like why am I you
know in the middle of Disneyland and I'm
having a panic attack and I'm like oh
because my mom made me swim through
lightning storms like you just don't
know yeah how it's gonna present in your
body I think yeah that is that's scary
and I hear you
like they're things that you don't know
why they're happening but like you also
are kind of like oh okay well well I
just saw this thing that was like
um childhood trauma it was in a TED Talk
Like childhood trauma is like your
doctor should be asking you about it
because it could like take 20 years off
your life like it's actually this like a
serious health condition and I'm like
well [ __ ] like I don't know anyone who
hasn't had any like some form of
childhood trauma like who had a I don't
know who had like the perfect childhood
Carlos did you have a good childhood
yeah I had a great childhood oh okay so
that's why he eats hookers out
but it's like such a such a powerful
move I know you bring it up every
episode
it really like I really heard about
doing that isn't that amazing he's such
a great guy I wanted them to have a good
time too wow what a cool dude I almost
want to get uh I come second
if you're getting I come first I'll go I
got that okay great wait should I be
third
we all know Esther you're you're never
gonna
you're never going to be third in any
situation thank you
[Music]
we talk about sometimes about like a
pillow princess era and just like you
know just being a receiver in bed do it
is that do you ever identify as that oh
I I've identify or or do I live that or
hell no I have to active participant oh
yeah yeah oh yeah oh I could never just
lay there and just and and just be the
one getting it all hell no just go okay
so I've been an active participant my
whole life and I'm really inspired by
Esther's like pillow princess nature and
so now I'm trying to enter that phase in
my life where I'm just like I just want
to sit back and receive but I'm having
trouble like I really it really is hard
for me I'm I'm an athlete you know yeah
you want to hop on that thing I do get
to riding yeah yeah you want to put some
work in yeah I do it's like I want to
burn calories I want to sweat a little
bit like let me earn this come you know
that's funny oh my God I was recently
talking to this actress and she was
telling me like how
when she was younger she like if she
needed to like lose a little weight she
would just start hooking up with guys
because she was such an active sexual
partner like that was how she like did
got her Fitness and got her heart rate
up yeah burned us away I was like is
that the ultimate hot girl plan hot girl
workout plan dude that's great yeah why
are they going for a jog I yeah yeah
that's awesome spreading Joy like making
people happy I don't know Chelsea when
you've been with someone for 16 years
like like what are the conversations
like around sex like you always joke
about like oh let me I would you know I
would absolutely like have a fresh piece
but like
um
I feel like we don't talk about about it
much anymore I'm like the one that's
like hey you want a threesome he's like
no
and I'm like hey you want to try this
toy and he's like he's like very vanilla
not into anything and I'm like the one
that's like let's like get wild and do
something like let's swap with somebody
or let's like let's like you know uh use
this toy or whatever and he is the
complete opposite so I feel like it used
to be not a fight but it almost used to
be like a frustration and now I just
realize that that's who he is and this
is who I am so it's it's just it's chill
now but it used to be more of a more of
a conversation more of a frustration but
God we've been together so long it's
it's you know it's not anymore so we
don't even talk about it anymore
honestly I know he does not want a
threesome he does not want to swap he
does not want a [ __ ] ring so I just let
it
well I just learned from Esther that the
symbol for swingers is pineapple yes do
you know this I knew this yeah upside
down pineapple right oh I didn't know
that have you come ever come across it
or been like approached no not with a
pineapple no no but I I put like um I
did know that and I I put a pineapple
wallpaper in my office without without
like knowing because it does have to be
upside down I didn't know that but this
was just pink pineapples and I thought
it was cute oh it sent an uproar on
Instagram no messaging me like I'm I
knew you guys were swingers like I'm
like chill out I have heard that though
whoa like if you have your pineapple
upside down in the grocery store
that means another swinger can approach
you
give each other information and then
y'all will hook up with yeah I like
cannot that's so small town to me to
like picture like you're finding your
swingers at the grocery store like
that's inspiring me to want to like meet
people at Whole Foods Silver Lake yeah
like I just want to make new friends
well apparently they do that at cruise
ships too where they put the sign on
their door so they know like who's
swinging and who's not and you know
whose door to knock on if you want to
switch a roux I feel like also this
stuff may have been like old school
people now just hop on websites that's
true but I have been on that website and
I do not like it why
um any like I think it's called um
finder no it's like it used to be
thrinder but then now it's
um and it's just couples on there yeah
it's the one um and told um me about it
it's where she's had like successful
like threesomes with people right where
she was the wasn't she a third or did
she bring a third in I think if you're
the third they call you the Unicorn
right I have heard that right yes
because or apparently that that's rare
right to find a good third right so
you're like a unicorn I have heard that
that's kind of fun
um but I've been on it and I it's it's
so limited I almost feel like going to
the grocery store and just flipping the
pineapple is the ultimate way especially
at Erawan oh
I when I go to the grocery store I'm
looking
I am just to just to see if it's and I
have yet to see an upside down pineapple
what if it what about if it's a can of
pineapple oh I don't know that might be
hard to hard to spot you can spot a
pineapple a mile away but I am honestly
looking because I want to know like does
this still happen I haven't seen it
wow I know it's a real thing I am now
just like is it bad that sometimes me
and Dave called donut are third
like is she our unicorn I mean she does
come in for the Deep um mouth kisses
right yeah
oh my God she's she's the third yeah
y'all are making out yeah he's the third
that's cute is it is it okay it is oh I
think making out with dogs is fine yeah
okay good I'm a big makeout with dogs
same person um I know that people are
weirded out about it because of what
like they are freaking parasites it's
like that's a small price to pay
diarrhea is a small price to pay for me
feeling my dog's love I agree I agree
wholehearted people are repulsed by it I
posted a video of um my dog Gobi kissing
my mouth while I was singing like an
ABBA song and people were upset like
really genuinely upset
oh I know it's so I kiss my dogs all the
time my dogs aren't really tongue dudes
but I will just oh my God I will
borderline smother them and when I feel
them needing air that's when I give up
but I will just hope my dogs are real
little and I'll just hold them and just
just so they're fighting for air
I love dog kisses me too I feel like
that is like my most raw form of joy is
just like the moments with my dog like
what else on life in life is is
important or is is I don't know that's
what I feel like a human creature having
The Full Experience oh I'm obsessed with
my dogs yeah they're Mama's world I
could sit here and talk about them for
an hour dude like they are Mama's world
so I get it dude I get it how many do
you have I've got two
um they're real little Tilly and Gary
Gary Gary great name for a dog he's a
Japanese Chin and they're both real
little I mean Gary's not that big
Tilly's like that big and their mom is
everything but dude there and I don't
have kids and I don't plan on having
kids and people always ask me are you
gonna get a third dog and I'm like hell
no why these they are a full-time job
they really are Tilly's easy Tilly I
don't have to mess with don't have to
care for Gary it is like watching a
toddler
and I that that solidified that I don't
want kids I think getting Gary big time
so they're a lot dude you have dogs it's
a lot I have four so
and there my all four were like
unadoptables they came from like rescues
and they were dogs that just had a hard
time
um being placed in homes because they
either had a behavioral issue
and so full-time job it is oh bless your
heart that's sweet but four of them oh
my gosh uh-uh couldn't do it barely
handle too when I was locked up in a
psychiatric hospital as a teenager
um there was
um we there was an adult area there was
like where the teenagers were and there
was an area that had like more minors in
it and there was a kid there who was
eight years old who was non-verbal but
she wasn't non-verbal because of a
learning disability she was non-verbal
because her mother or her parents
um raised her like a dog I don't you can
I know this is a touchy subject for you
Esther but kept her in like a dog shed
in the back leashed and everything and I
remember hearing that story and thinking
like jeez like
my upbringing so what about the
lightning storms like yeah I'm good yeah
which goes back to exactly what I was
saying like bro it could be so much work
yeah it could and I've I've heard of it
might have been that same story I have
heard of that that is crazy does that
bring up feelings for yester
well of jealousy no well because she was
a dog for a part of her life oh I know
she's jealous she wasn't racist I as a
child identified as a dog named Jacob
and I really just I really wanted to be
a dog and I had to laugh but they're
laughing over there so it's making me
laugh okay it's good okay and
um I've noticed that years later my
adult life that is kind of coming up
again and I'm like I really do want to
sort of be like
somewhere between like a dog and an
inanimate object like is sort of a safe
place for me for how long
you know when you were a dog uh I was
probably only a dog for less than a year
when I was little you know old time or
like in in between schools or I'm being
serious no okay I think like mostly full
time I would uh bite people I would only
eat off of the floor
and you're so tiny now I imagine you
being so little I was a small dog like
the teacup dog yeah thank you
thank you for that but it is I don't
know why as a child I wanted to be a dog
I think I just met a dog and wanted to
become it and now
okay is it this can I talk about this is
my stand-up like is it that crazy though
to want at least like a 34 year old
woman to want to a little bit be treated
like a dog do you guys get what I'm
saying just pup play pup play is a real
thing that is a thing yeah puppy play is
where they dress up and they really
really take on the spirit of a dog and
it's it's very sexual but maybe you can
do pup play but more just in your real
life like a furry
I don't think anything's weird and I'm
being serious like if you're like you
know so if it makes somebody happy and
you're not hurting people I don't think
anything's weird uh you want to get a
caller and I'll I'll [ __ ] walk you
out in the parking lot you know I was
like I think you should do it
whatever makes you happy for real
people do weirder [ __ ] man like what oh
god people call into our podcast we take
calls from people and [ __ ] sometimes is
so wild like we can't even play a call
man like people just people do the
weirdest [ __ ] we had a lady call in and
she was like I found out my my brother
his wife called me and was like I have
to tell you like your brother she like I
think had to tell her because she had to
tell somebody your brother loves to put
um soap bars up his butthole
and just keep them in there
and I guess just push them out when he's
done
wait why do people just do weird jobs I
can kind of understand because maybe
there is some type of like Freudian
thing happening there because I know
that the anal stage is real and maybe
that was not properly handled when he
was a kid but wait the anal stage what
are you talking about there is um like
anal like it's uh you could pull it up
the Freudian stages the anal stage and
Freudian psychology is a period of human
development occurring at about one to
three years of age around this age a
child begins to toilet train which
brings about the child's Fascination in
the erogenous zone of the anus the
erogenous zone is focused on the bowel
and bladder I cannot have kids this is
like too complicated you have to deal
with a kid becoming obsessed with their
anus yeah I don't want to do that but
you know when when parents are like well
they don't remember anything between one
and three uh just kidding if you if you
get that [ __ ] wrong they're gonna stick
soap bars up their [ __ ] as adults
yeah but um last night
um my family and I brought all the
mattresses to the living room and
because my mom wanted to watch Pretty
Woman as a family
and then
um
randomly Bobby comes through the living
room and he wants he wants to ruin this
perfectly sweet moment he was like
Richard Gere he's like yeah he puts
gerbils up his [ __ ]
and you're like what and is that like a
he says it's like an urban famous Urban
myth yeah that he did it yeah that
people do it that Richard here yeah I
feel so bad perpetuating this but I have
to ask like what does your mom act like
or think like when Bobby Lee walks in
the room and says that like what does
your mom think of you and that whole
thing my mom and Bobby are two peas in a
pod no two people get along more they
just get each other there's a language
barrier it doesn't matter they're both
[ __ ] crazy I should have known like
um I upset my mom the other day and he
completely sided with her
he was like you're dumb no apologize I'm
like
yeah and what are you talking she's my
perpetrator
but there actually is an origin to the
Richard Gere story oh God which is
that's uh sliced alone apparently made
up a rumor on the 1974 film The Lord's
the Flatbush and the two actors got into
a tiff over lunch one day something
about chicken grease
and
um they got in an argument in this how
the Oh how it all started uh oh yeah me
and Annie's biggest fight was about
chicken grease as well really
why no I'm just kidding
this holiday season if you are looking
for like a unique gift that inspires
curiosity we all know that travel lover
people who are into culture give the
gift of Babel Babel is the language
learning app that has sold more than 10
million subscription and thanks to
Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you'll
finally be able to discover the wonder
that comes with learning a new language
I mean as someone who's still trying to
learn the English language this is huge
someone buy this for me for Christmas so
I can learn English what I love with
Babel is that they have 10 minute
lessons yeah like it doesn't take a
whole day it doesn't take a couple hours
they give it to you in like little fun
bite-sized sessions and don't you find
when you do learn a language don't you
feel like so like how disrespectful was
I that I didn't even try to attempt to
learn another language it feels so good
to be able to communicate with people
when you go to another country it feels
so nice to be able to get around yeah
and people really appreciate that
um as someone who grew up in another
country I love it when people tried to
learn the basics thank you how are you
how much like I love that effort I think
that goes a long way when you're
traveling don't learn how much first
don't be rude oh my God you want to turn
on an Italian man just be the little
helpless American girl who only knows
but a few words is an Italian only a 10
minute lesson or two
right now sorry sorry right now get up
to 55 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com trash Tuesday that's
babble.com trash Tuesday for up to 55
off your subscription Babel language for
life does ZocDoc have a um jingle I feel
like you'd be like zoc doc zoc doc this
is awesome zocdoc's the best you guys
because how many times have you gone to
a bad doctor and gone I wish there was a
freaking Yelp for this I have a tickle
in my throat right now
she honestly don't feel great either I
feel great because I go to ZocDoc and
what I love about ZocDoc is that for so
long like we've been reading reviews for
restaurants for food for every other
place but doctors where it's actually
needed and now with stock talk you can
search for a doctor that your insurance
covers
um you can search for a doctor's with
real patient reviews I don't know that's
just peace of mind to me I like a
specific type of doctor like you don't
want to be too chatty like don't get too
friendly doc all right we know we've had
those before but like you want them to
be like you trust them you know they're
actually listening to there's been so
many doctors I've had that if I've just
had to go to urgent care or something
they're so rude I don't want to be like
shamed when I go to the doctor for a
cough ZocDoc is a free app that shows
you doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance and are available
when you need them on ZocDoc you can
find every specialist Under the Sun
whether you're trying to straighten your
teeth fix an achy back at them we'll
check out anything ZocDoc has you
covered and zocdoc's mobile app is as
easy as ordering a ride to a restaurant
or getting delivery to your house search
fine and book doctors with a few Taps go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash zoctalk
zocdoc.com trash
Oh My Gosh but I have heard people
people love to do weird [ __ ] and I have
heard that gerbil thing people love to
do that all right that one makes me sad
because it's hurting an animal I agree
big time yeah I agree with anything in
your butt my dad told me at the ER that
he would see just the craziest stuff in
the world in that like he wouldn't he
said he couldn't even like talk to me
when he would come home from work
because he would see such insane stuff
we like animals like rodents and stuff
and this is what your dad has to do to
buy you cotton citizen are you how do
you feel about that that was 20 years
ago as an ER doctor oh my gosh we had
somebody call into the Pod and she had
said that her husband she had caught her
husband I guess he had put a um plunger
up against the wall and he was putting
it in his ass I don't know I can't
remember they call exactly what had
happened but somehow they needed to go
to the ER and he was mortified and he
told the doctor instead of being like
yeah I stuck it up my ass which
everybody knows that's what happened
yeah he told the doctor
that he was walking across the room and
tripped
[Laughter]
landed and it landed in there
literally that's why he told and she was
she was embarrassed by that yeah that's
way more embarrassing than what actually
happened oh my God yeah see if guys were
to just openly admit that ass play is I
mean feels phenomenal none of these ER
visits would be necessary just tell us
you want stuff up there I'll I'll put
stuff up there whatever it is you want
yes the answer is yes wait so guys like
us played like yes I haven't been with a
guy
um and even the most resistant ones if
I'm just like hey just relax I don't I
need you to just take all of your
preconceived whatever out the way just
let me touch it a little bit and see if
you like it then it's usually a very
lubed up finger not to go in but just to
touch it and I'm like be real with me
how does that feel and the answer is
always that felt pretty good always it's
such an erogenous Soul this is very in a
line with this Theory I have about you
that you very there's a Venn diagram and
here is sex acts and here is like being
a medical professional and you're in the
middle like you are this like sexual
medical
experience for people it's like sexual
icky guy yeah and the calming voice
should like sit back
because it's kind of like no judgment
like I just want to know like let's see
and if you don't like it you don't like
it no big deal I'll never touch you
there again but can I just try let's
just try it yeah we're taking a banana
break yes I need a
love this it's just it's not nothing
sexual it's just for potassium yeah just
a snack just a snake
disease yeah but if it starts to
resemble a perfume bottle feel free
love me a banana mm-hmm
I die without bananas um
I live and die by this thing do you like
banana pudding I love anything banana
but wasn't we kind of all at least agree
that like the banana flavor Laffy Taffy
was not that's my number one why you're
one of those people
that's the only one I like
oh the bananas so good it's so strange
to me oh God it's so good that's my
number one mm-hmm
which is the best one Nester
I think they all taste the same except
the banana just tastes weird like
they're all good because it's more of a
synthetic banana yeah right well isn't
banana
how do you recreate the flavor of a
banana like I don't or recreate a scent
how do you do that you know like they'll
have like I don't know scent like
candles and like I've always wondered
that how do you recreate scents and
tastes don't know
chemists that's wild they're smart yeah
science or something like that
you don't like banana sunnies oh I I
like to save mine and make it into a
milkshake when I get home smart I know
that isn't like the intention of the
banana break but I
I'm Jewish and so I'm doing it my way
this is actually how they recreate
fragrances they put a sample into this
machine
right there that cost thousands of
dollars they break it down to its
molecular level and their components and
then they recreate it synthetically
whoa yeah so it seems very time science
stuff yeah it's like I think it's a very
serious thing that's and that's why
McDonald's french fries taste good
because of science you know
people are very against synthetic
um ingredients or synthetic like
chemicals like put into their cosmetics
and things like that and everyone always
pushes up for the on the label all
natural natural this natural that i'm
like [ __ ] cyanide is natural like most
poisonous things are natural like a lot
of synthetic stuff is actually safer for
consumption than all natural stuff but
people don't want to like
they're so hell-bent on like what that
labeling looks like it's kind of this
like weird brainwashing especially skin
care skincare is a big people are all
natural but a lot of a lot of all
natural skin care will break you the
[ __ ] yeah I have eczema so things like
peppermint [ __ ] me up like a lot of
things and also highly toxic for animals
too like you can't just have like
peppermint oil you know like right wait
why
um why peppermint oil I think that's
toxic for dogs there's a lot of
essential oils that you have to be
really careful around animals a lot of
flowers you have to be very careful with
tulips or lilies and not tulips lilies
around cats it can cause renal failure
yeah peppermint oil is not safe for dogs
I think it kills roaches yeah I mean
citronella kills mosquitoes right it's
like
natural is dangerous yeah nature is a
beast just because it's all natural
doesn't mean you're going to react well
to it yep my PSA amen amen well it's
like when people say like no chemicals
it's like okay well you know that you're
a chemical
[Laughter]
bro you're a [ __ ] chemical so Charles
do you know what a pleasure Dom is no
dominatrix oh you're gonna like this one
I know you're gonna like this one what
is it pull it up okay so a pleasure Dom
is basically a guy and his only desire
and his job is to make you come over and
over and over again and so on tigerbelly
I had talked about also on this show I
had talked about this one guy named yini
and he's um adult film star and he's a
pleasure Dom and so basically I was like
oh I have a celebrity crash in his it's
this guy
and um
I thought this was a truly asked comment
but Pete this
it's not a huge celebrity yet
I
um he's like really hot to me I mean
you're just doing YouTubers now or what
no I mean
do we mean like a movie star or
something what the actual [ __ ] she is so
so attractive also she wanted to like
you know DM me on Instagram you know
maybe she sees this
hold up I thought this was there you go
hey
have you boned him no are you gonna he
dm'd me on Instagram I I don't know what
to say back what did he say can you tell
him yeah oh
wait also can you like what does he do
like is that his thing like does he porn
star and he like gets off on yeah he
just makes him calm like hard over and
over again but is he like that in real
life
yeah yeah yeah
but what if you get all this hype up and
you bone him and he just
sticks it in and comes and leaves
no that's not happening it better not he
says oh he's hot he says the little
crush is mutual if you ever really
wanted to have me on or if you wanted to
grab dinner sometime I'm sure we could
coordinate something
oh would you say God I haven't said
anything back
I think he needs to be a guest on um
that night yeah we'll just skip dinner
just keep it I have a sweat mustache
that's how you know I'm really nervous
I'm officially inviting him to guests on
this show you you know where to find us
we want you we we want to bring you in
here we want to talk it out
in person yeah you gotta
you gotta just sit back relax you can be
the pillow princess
yeah so I think he's a perfect guy
um to really push me into that pillow
princess era because I imagine me like
fighting back and him like just pushing
me back down and say telling me to do
nothing or like not move a muscle oh my
and I'm gonna resist right like this is
this is how I'm romanticizing it in my
head mhm that starts now
message him back it's it's a little bit
giving to me like The Vibes that you
also want to be an inanimate object
slash dog you want to like have someone
just be like sit
stay that's funny yeah make me fight my
own nature is the best way to like turn
me on because like
just tell me no I can't do it yeah
I think I'm about to come right now
we have to take a break oh my gosh oh my
God what are you nervous about I I just
like I haven't been a single in a really
long time and so God you got to keep us
updated yeah I will I want to know I
want to know what's the caressa method
for successor
I don't know
Carls what is that I'm pulling it up
right now it's more it's like when you
Embrace while [ __ ] right back wait
[ __ ] sensual it's basically not chasing
the come ah not chasing the gum it's all
about yeah it comes from the Italian
word caressa which means caress
and it's all about intimacy without
orgasm as the goal oh that's more
eloquent way of putting like edging
um yeah well it's more like at the idea
that sex isn't like
um orgasm isn't the point of two people
coming together like embracing kissing
touching you know feeling all of the the
sensations that comes with two Warm
Bodies together I kind of get that I do
but I'm skeptical like was this invented
by a guy who doesn't want to make a girl
come like that it's like feels a little
lazy so are they not coming at all like
when you get close you're done like you
stop no you can't you come you just
enjoy the right because there have been
I think if I can look back at my
favorite sexual partner of my entire
life it was a guy who like we would just
start [ __ ] but then we would just
sometimes stop and it'll be like it will
finish later but it was nice to just um
be close and [ __ ] for yeah this long
yeah this says if orgasming feels like
it's the best thing to do in the moment
then great let whatever ever happen be
okay
okay yeah Esther I feel like you're not
on board it's very vague I I I'm just
skeptical like I do understand it though
like obviously there's times where it's
just about like physical touch but you
want a nut I look
you want a nut yeah I think as a proud
leader of the feminist sexual orgasm
movement
I think it's my job to make sure that I
don't leave a sexual experience without
a nut
a nut yeah I love coming I get that I
love coming too but I think that it um I
like all of it I like anything I like
feeling horny feeling horny is my
favorite feeling in the world
more more so than feeling safe like
feeling horny that's so funny like you
that's so [ __ ] up like just take away
safety and you might not think that oh
my God no but I mean just like even like
that that moment where you're like oh I
I am a little bit horny to create
sensation and that carries over into
just making out with someone and edging
I love that because it's like a thing
that builds it's almost like a like a
the pressure you don't feel that way do
you feel like if you had only just been
horny and turned on you would have been
okay in the swimming pool with a
lightning storm like that that would
have made it all right rub one out
looking at the sky safety would not
matter yeah
but I was a horny oh I don't want to
talk about me as a horny kid
super pillows I made I I had two bears
named emno and emny and they would just
were they like discount Elmo's why did
they have this name I have no idea but
it was em no and emni and they were just
two teddy bears and they were like they
would violently [ __ ]
did you come pillows I would hunt
pillows I would hump my dolls I would
hump the furniture
when everyone was gone I would [ __ ] the
whole house
I would hump everything I'm not even
kidding that was my only fans idea to
hunt pillows without my face oh that's
right yeah so we have this idea for
Carlos where we think
um we think he should have sex with
pillows but different kinds of pillows
and see like you know like a Target
pillow versus a Marlow pillow versus
like a Four Seasons pillow right because
I don't think all pillows are built the
same no definitely not and you talked
about previously like liking humping
pillows I mean I come from the Chelsea
School of masturbation for sure yeah you
talk to house no I mean I I didn't go
whole house I just did pillows pillows
there was a girl right there was a girl
in my Catholic school and all girls
catholic school and she was like horned
up all the time and she got suspended
because she started
um humping the edge of her chair because
it was like a pointed chair and she
would just back up into it like in class
yeah
I waited till I got home man in class in
class Chelsea thank you so much for
coming today oh my gosh this was awesome
dude you are such a ray of sunshine
thank you we love you thank you all of
y'all hope you come back every time
you're in town I will thank you for
having me and maybe Paige can maybe come
on the show someday oh she would love
that show us um how to properly um do
fart art because dude we're coming back
and you'll have to have her on and she
will do live fart art for you guys
please seriously you big fart guy
that was just so funny to me it's just
funny to him so funny he's very and
energized today
we we love that for you we're happy for
you be open-minded oh I just announced
um a tour I'm going on tour so come and
see me
um tickets go on sale this week
um um so yeah come see me on the road
and I have a podcast called devour
podcast and yeah and tell us will you
send us um your new calendar
yes I will I should have brought some
I'm sorry I will send them to you I do a
calendar every year if you knew this
it is a topless calendar
and I do it in in the trailer trash
Tammy character and they are hilarious
it's the number one thing I do each year
I mean p like this is like a big thing
like that I sell so many [ __ ] titty
calendars
and I will send each of y'all a titty
counter thank you that's all I want wow
I'm I'm really inspired today you guys
thank you so much for listening check
out Chelsea on tour and her podcast and
her calendar and we will see you next
week as always the brand new episode of
trash Tuesday bye guys
foreign
[Music]